m
[Musique]
connaissez-vous le quartier de saint
germain des prés saint germain des prés
les vestiges de la plus ancienne abbaye
le parc précieux reste de l'
architecture religieuse du 11e siècle un
quartier provinciale où l'on peut depuis
la rome antique petite place de pioche
timbert jeter un coup d'oeil sur
l'atelier ou delacroix bouleversa la
peinture de son temps et d'ailleurs ce
sont bien ces souvenirs d'un quartier où
elle a grandi et que corinne calvet
retour d'hollywood a voulu montrer à son
mari le neveu de louis braille fils vous
croyez en vous savez saint-germain
beaucoup changé entre-temps le floor par
exemple café non tombe avec ses
servantes et c'est pontife leur
apostolat implique le renoncement à
toute pompe vestimentaire et l'humilité
la plus totale dans le choix des
véhicules
mais n'est ce pas là une forme moderne
de la mortification peut-être d'ailleurs
l'exemple vient de haut degré co la
première vestale d'un culte dont jean
paul sartre et simone de beauvoir on
peut être involontairement déchaîné les
manifestations qui se réclament de leur
philosophie de l'existence d'un oui
l'existentialisme l'existentialisme ce
que vous en savez vous autres ne vous
fâchez pas ne vous fâchez pas d'ailleurs
nous allons pénétrer ensemble dans les
lieux où l'on sait première station la
librairie où tout ce qui a trait à
l'existentialisme se trouve condensé
dans un magasin exceptionnellement
située à 3 mètres au dessus du niveau de
la mer
ici l'esprit sabreurs le corps aussi
d'ailleurs
depuis les mains sales jusqu'au deuxième
sexe tous les évangiles ils sont réunis
dans la rue saint-benoît plaque
tournante de l'existentialisme il ne
faut pas se fier aux enseignes car si
l'existence ses exigences et si
l'épicière à 5h fait l'épicière à 8
heures elle fait salon un salon de trois
mètres sur 4 prévu pour contenir 150
personnes au salon où la fantaisie du
peintre du king a matérialisé sur les
crânes des idées pas pilot
9h30 on entasse les clients de la
verticale deuxième station la
discothèque sanctuaire où le common
entre pas mûres qu'aucune lamentations
ne saurait et brûlé seul dans le monde
319 bien heureux détenteurs d'une clé
peuvent y pénétrer car pour franchir le
seuil de ce paradis il faut la clé
évidemment ce parti et son terrain là
onze mille disques parmi les plus rares
offres aux 319 élus ont choisi
inépuisable de danse rituelle exécuté
dans une atmosphère tout de quiétude et
de recueillement et dites moi il ya un
côté très sport ben oui le sport tient
une grande place à saint germain des
prés sur tous les sports d'adressent
mais c'est vraiment dans la danse que
l'existentialisme tour sa plus belle
expression troisième station le club
saint germain 23 mètres au dessous du
niveau de la mer la cave par excellence
et sous l'oeil des dieux les rats
attends se liera penseurs de herat
cajoleur
lra africains les reins américain eh
bien oui quoi des rats terreur des rats
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
dise moi c'est ça la belle
l'existentialisme
[Musique]